we came to Rome to shoot a chasing
something with a lot more ambition and
unpredictability that we haven't had in
previous chases
we'll be screaming through the streets
of Rome Motorcycles
Cars everything that we shot me is
completely practical
we're doing it right
it all comes down to one thing how do we
involve the audience I just want to give
them that thrill
[Music]
[Applause]
we let the city tell us the kind of
Chase it was going to be traffic in the
city is notorious and the cobblestone
streets make all of the driving
unpredictable
[Music]
best part is Tom and Haley
they're handcuffed together
people are chasing us yes they are
you're driving
[Applause]
Tom Nets Drive one-handed cuffed for
real no cheating it the key is don't
crash
[Applause]
he's that person I have no idea
come driving and drifting one-handed
through the streets of Rome that was a
day I will never forget trying to do
drifts every time you think you're going
in One Direction it's the cobblestones
on the street saying no you're not
you're going this way
you gotta get rid of this car
[Applause]
[Music]
Tom and Haley ditched the car for one of
their IMF there because
suddenly this tiny little Fiat 500 comes
out of nowhere we built this Fiat 500
so that it would be faster
you could barely control the car it was
treacherous the Fiat that was wild some
would even say the car is possessed
I don't think we could have made a
sequence that was more difficult to
shoot if I had gone out of my way to do
it it has really amazing results
[Applause]
would be impossible without this crew of
an actor like Tom
we lost them
thank you